we get everybody ready for sunday with
et's big super bowl playbook
55 hours before kickoff the weekend
posted this new video
casually dining on the field and caught
in an avalanche of footballs
but don't expect the weekend to pull any
surprises out of his playbook
yup even though he's collabed with big
names like ariana grande
nicki minaj and drake there will not be
any other stars at halftime
there wasn't any room to fit it in the
narrative in the story i was telling so
yeah there's no special guests
another move from the playbook attention
to every detail
jesse collins who's the executive
producer of the pepsi super bowl
halftime show
told me the singer is working through
every single nuance
how's he handling the moment so far just
like super focused
going through the music you know like oh
maybe we should have a flute perhaps a
bell
is there a xylophone and earned it and
you deserve
it of course the weekend is just part of
the star-studded lineup
country music's eric church and r b's
jasmine sullivan
will sing the national anthem i think
it'll be cool to blend
the different sounds of music and and
just show some unity
grammy winner her performs america the
beautiful
will you have a guitar out there with
you
[Music]
and miley cyrus has been hitting the
treadmill prepping for her performance
at the tick tock tailgate pre-show
this year only about 25 000 fans will be
in the stadium
that includes vaccinated healthcare
workers and listen to this
there will be thirty thousand life-size
cutouts et has learned those cutouts
will include
images of jon hamm kevin hart tiffany
haddish and shaquille o'neal who will
also be there in real life
you're gonna be at the game of course as
for who's on the field
for one tom brady it's his 10th super
bowl appearance
hey tom hi camille how you doing brady
talked with gronk's girl as he and rob
debuted their new super bowl ad
jokingly revealing spotty cell service
was the reason tom didn't retire
what do you think my next move should be
just come to florida and feel the wind
in your hair
retirement is like winning another one
maybe i'll even
join you this is what tom heard just
come to florida
and win another one maybe i'll even join
you just go with another one
like it's that easy gronk maybe it is i
got
a kick out of it because you did pretty
good i have to say
what's feel good gearing up for super
bowl rob
and you know what he's super excited
because um
you know he feels so good mom where are
my football pants
we rely on each other a lot for
different things and
you know i'll be looking for them this
sunday so that's the most important
thing the best part about winning is
having the people
that have helped you get there and
support you there with you to enjoy it
some of the best memories i've had in my
life were being with my kids right after
the super bowl and
celebrating with them so i hope we have
that experience on sunday
brady and mahomes two great teams it
just comes at a perfect time
cbs's sports team jim nance tony romo
and tracy wolfson will be calling the
shots
tracy can't wait to hit the field that
is definitely something i missed
you know being up in the stands
throughout this season more girl power
in the game
six women including two pairs of female
assistant coaches
and athletic trainers and in a super
bowl first
a woman will referee it means a lot to
me
i have a precious little girl that is
watching her mom
i want her to know seeing it believing
it
and you can do it sarah thomas's
eight-year-old daughter bailey may just
follow in her mom's milestone footsteps
she said monday asked what i wanted to
do in the future and i told him i wanted
to be a mom
a teacher and a rep like my mom
and the beauty of it is that one day she
can all right let's head back to camille
kostik in tampa
look camille no doubt about who you're
pulling for your boyfriend
is buccaneers tight end rob gronkowski
yes the gronk and now i'm predicting two
touchdown passes from tom this game
but of course the chiefs do have their
hot shot qb
patrick mahomes the big goat versus the
little goat
tom brady gisele's man 43 years old
father of three
six super bowl wins
patrick mahomes is just 25 and won his
first super bowl
last year he was in first grade when tom
won his first championship in 2002.
our super bowl rings and trophies and
all that fun stuff
brady is estimated to be worth 200
million dollars but mahomes who is 18
years younger
is the 500 million dollar man after
signing a long-term contract with the
chiefs
he also reportedly earns almost 7
million a year
in endorsements i ate 100 of my green
beans 100
don't like them 100 don't care before
patrick was even born
tom was the quarterback at sarah high in
san mateo california
back in the early 90s his favorite
target on the football field was john
kirby who i spoke to exclusively
did you think he would end up being the
greatest of all time
oh no not at all actually in high school
a lot of us thought that he was going to
be a professional baseball player that
was more
what he was known for in our area brady
complete to kirby at the 20 to the 10.
i can tell you kevin running around the
field catching passes from tommy back in
high school i can honestly tell you 100
we would never thought in our wildest
dreams that he would be the greatest
quarterback of all time but it was
definitely an honor
to be out there for almost two decades
and many different hairstyles e.t has
spent a lot of time with the goat
do you ever think about maybe crossing
over to the entertainment world
it's too hard man it's too hard it's
much easier playing football out here
one secret to the success of his
marriage to giselle she's my best friend
so i think he just
uh you know we spend as much time as we
can together and
you know it's a busy life we have
you have peace and quiet with three kids
i locked the door
i locked the door patrick is engaged to
his high school sweetheart
personal trainer brittany matthews and
this spring
he will become a girl dad we will be
having
baby and 20 21 and then we plan to do
wedding and all
wedding things um 20 22.
[Music]